let's talk about this you wrote this
very nice book the actor's life a
Survival Guide and what's nice about
this is that hard to believe but you've
spent about 20 years in Hollywood
you started out driving out here and
you're in your car my monster hatchback
your Mazda hatchback like a lot of
people and getting started and so very
relatable this is a good book for people
to check out if they want to know what
it's really like to get started in the
business yeah you know I've been out
here for 20 years but I didn't get my
first paid acting job until like year
three I didn't get on TV until you're
five and I didn't get the office until
you're eight Wow
where did you where did you live what
kind of apartment oh I lived in a
horrible place in West Hollywood when I
first moved here not because West
Hollywood is bad West Hollywood is great
but I moved in with a friend of mine
that I'd gone to college with this guy
who had been living on someone's couch
for a year and he heard I was coming out
and he said he'd get us an apartment and
I just advice to anyone is like don't
let maybe like a 22 year old dude who's
been living on someone's couch pick your
apartment for you because for him
anything is a step up and so the place
that he picked was it was very dingy and
dark and like my cat got so depressed
living there that he was like licking
out patches of his fur is depressed by
an apartment there like meant to live
like you know what I mean in the woods
in someone some twigs when they're in an
apartment and saying I want to kill
myself I know my sister wouldn't shower
in the apartment she calls a place with
the scary bathroom mm-hmm so when she
would visit she would go shower at my
parents hotel my parents never stayed
there
no I so their love is conditional
clearly on you living in a nice
yeah there you go
I've always wondered how they felt about
the fact that my bedroom window backed
up to the famous West Hollywood sex toy
shop The Pleasure Chest did it yes that
was my backyard yeah that's a thumbs
down but they were acting out something
you could purchase the kind of show we
got here ladies and gentlemen it was a
weirdly it was a very safe place to live
though I mean it was it was a weirdly it
was it like this it was on the up-and-up
there are nerves yeah it's a mom-and-pop
business trying to make it that's all it
is yeah oh good plug for the pleasure
testers never thought I would but you're
here for
you